so when i'm here i'm thinking how do i  help a mom with ptsd who just got back  from war and her husband cheated on her  but now that man we're not there  like how do you have a conversation at  the table right how do you sleep all  night how do you  say like how do you take conflict  conversations and talk about  talk about conversations hard  conversations and then get into person  like hey we've been married for 10 years  and our sex life is gone and i don't  know how to say this nobody trained me  how to say this but i think you don't  love me like how do you do that it all  starts with sitting on a table and being  like  hey what would you rather do at a date  fart or burp right